pour sommer à tout vent la vérité des
arts de la table la maison larousse a
réuni un comité éditorial impressionnant
où se sont retrouvés notamment les chefs
joël robuchon michel guérard et pierre
troisgros le maître chocolatier robert
linxe et l'artiste pâtissier pierre
hermé le résultat de leur travail
le larousse gastronomique à le volume
d'un dictionnaire de 1200 pages ou
abonder les recettes mais aussi les
hommes les produits et l'histoire
l'idée n'est pas neuve puisque dès 1938
et sous la même enseigne
prosper montagné publié déjà un larousse
gastronomique mais le traitement est
tout autre en cela que l' ouvrage
proposé aujourd'hui qui est à la fois de
l'encyclopédie du goût et du livre de
recettes
ainsi par exemple si vous ne vous sentez
pas tout à fait sûrs d'eux vous quant à
la signification des mots fricandeau
qu'une crépinette vous en trouverez ici
l'origine et la préparation histoire de
la mandarine et pâtisserie il y afférent
technique de luyas cuisine du paraguay
et de l'uruguay
biographie de curnonsky de briey savary
de carême tout est là y compris le
clavelin cette bouteille réservés aux
vins jaunes de château chalon